it has to be alan ahusa
alan alfred i guess i should intro
everyone hi everyone i'm alana i'm
playing fifa 21 and i've never played
fifa before i'm joined by
rahul kohli who plays like how much did
you just cough when i
introduced you mate is that what just
happened i did yeah
uh how much leaf have you played broth
like all my life in it you get me
also camera cuff paper sickening amount
of fifa
a lot of fifa oh yeah and we've also got
yusuf
who i think is with me on the the less
fifa but you have played fifa
uh i believe i've i coined the term fifa
oh yeah got a legend here the fully
intentional football association nice
so everything's gonna go great basically
but we are all liverpool supporters
and um we couldn't make liverpool
because i guess it doesn't work that way
so we're liverpoolish and i think we're
gonna do great
does it say c on you just because you're
captain who decided to make rahul
captain yeah i didn't consent to that
it did because you lot don't know how to
navigate the settings
yeah that's fair you got us there we
don't know how to navigate those
sessions unless alana you want to be
captain mate
no i'm good no i'm i want to captain i'm
too busy
uh being good at fifa and that do you
ever see on your own
i don't know yes i do yeah but it's just
because of the settings it's not it's
not getting to my head at all i promise
it's not an ego trick
that one the captain of this team no no
no
no what could go wrong oh they've got to
pick a different kit
that's going to be very confusing you're
right
yeah it looks like we're ready to be
watching around the world
it's not horrible you're gonna be guys
are you guys gonna be all right no i
look i don't i already don't know what
i'm doing bro
so turning ready for what should be
better pressure touch pad
the camera should be focusing on you
okay that worked
oh brilliant quick quick one down
we [ __ ]
[Laughter]
everyone if you look at your player
growth we've also got more stats for
them
oh my gosh my paces are great three
points all worth it
i got it cameron trying to sprint
cameron
that
i'm like here maybe not sure if useful
no no no you're doing the right thing
just okay getting in a good you know
being in an attack position be somewhere
that we can find
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right i'm learning it's okay it's
fine problem is i'm just so nervous you
guys i'm so nervous
all right
he is human nice
the uniform is so heinous they look like
there's 50 million i know and then
they've got their [ __ ] colorful hairs
do a green hair do with pink hair
welcome to pro clubs oh you tripped me
[ __ ] tripped me bro they know they
need to stop me
[Applause]
ah [ __ ]
once again i apologize for the it's it's
okay
hey i'm five seven all right okay
amazing
the benchmark of the population he's
like right in average
[Applause]
that did feel good it did feel good i'm
sorry
that they're in at the moment
well okay i get it okay i should have
passed it to someone okay i understand
yeah did you see that one
that you didn't [ __ ] pass no [ __ ]
all right yeah so i don't know how to
like do a header or anything i don't
know
and it was a brother as well [ __ ]
come get your man
come get your boy look how skinny our
keeper is
looks like an altar boy
you love to see it they couldn't quite
muster a real oh yes
oh okay i'm gonna cover you
it's all right it's okay
[Laughter]
will it be sufficiently imaginative will
it be sufficiently imaginative
double tap square oh [ __ ]
if you've done that a little bit sooner
he did say absolutely perfect but it was
pretty great
okay he the commentator said i did
something too early
all right so we've got one win which we
don't deserve uh disagree which we do
deserve i will take every win
the loss was not as bad as i expected if
i'm being honest and i think i've
learned
the chance there were like maybe a
couple of goals there that we probably
should have at least
tried for but we'll get there oh look
we're playing the british broadcasting
corporation
oh yeah yes that's what that stands for
so pure kim so pure
promising
okay we'll take the penalty but i would
have i felt like i was so set up to
score there
there we go we did it
we got our first goal let me drink the
tea
and we just celebrate around you here
you go
thank you i felt good about it i knew
what i was doing i was not confused you
know
so um that's a step forward
all right all right all right oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's all right sorry come on because i'm
just what if i just do that what if i
just [ __ ] do this
yes excellent use of the ball as they
make their way forward
oh i just wanted to go for it you know i
could have happened could have happened
all right i'm going to try and head this
down to you pierce or yusuf it's okay
no it's going to be pissed i'm going to
get there oh okay i got it but uh why
does it keep going
to the shortest person in the pitch i'm
calling all right okay someone could be
shorter than me we don't know everyone's
stats all right
okay again if you take a bench line out
of everyone
average exactly thank you cam i really
appreciate it
[Laughter]
i've had several girlfriends okay and it
not because of my money
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
you're too slippery for them because
you're so small or i'm good
it's just that i'm very good at what i'm
doing and they are on the move again
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] well he made that
interesting
everything if it wasn't [ __ ] cheaters
yeah they are doing that they absolutely
are doing that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
on a very easy yeah yeah we'll take that
we'll take a moral three
yeah i'm trying to remain calm but i'm
very angry right now
you're doing a good job colleen i'm
proud of the final 15 minutes the
therapy's been paid off
[ __ ] off dude i ran out of stamina
that's my phone
nice there you go there you go yes
oh you pieces of [ __ ] oh okay okay okay
okay okay okay that's good that's good
we like that we like that
oh you skipped it all right oh
okay we'll take it we'll take it we will
take it
but it was very funny i'm enjoying this
by the way
you know that's my first fifa experience
i this is i'm sorry i was
angry it's okay you knew that that was
going to happen you knew i was going to
get pissed off
you never need to apologize for that
that's passion yes
i have seen you quite angry at fifa in
my time that's why we love you
our only win was it was a forfeit but
consider this
one still one so still one did you think
about that
i don't accept that i don't win win is a
win
yep wins a win fam i think we played
great in that round that they forfeited
so
i'm just saying that was some of my
finest work
okay our aim in this match is to score a
goal and open play no pens
we're gonna try and get one goal in open
play that would be
fun that was an absolutely absurd goal
that was absolutely good
he did do that i don't think
with the insurance as a football player
you should be doing the damage
you could really hurt yourself
[Applause]
i really think he should be more careful
irresponsible not a great celebration
for some reason my announcer is from
1935. welcome back to the british
broadcasting corporation uh welcome back
tap to the british broadcasting
services our boys are out on the past
that last splendor
for not actively playing the game and it
might be
come on
[Applause]
i've got a bad feeling about this
rahul's really quiet
so you know something's up should i be
supporting you guys more i have been
just holding back where necessary go in
the middle
barking this guy [ __ ] off man they're
all over you
they're like possession if you have that
can they convert
what is wrong with our goalkeeper god
we're being rinsed here
what are you doing [ __ ] you now
are you okay rahul are you all right
nope nope nope
he's not all right no got it
not having a good time
come on
[Music]
holy [ __ ] and that will be all foreign